[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music
]
[Music]
What kind of styling do you dislike about white cake these days?
What color do you dislike?
You know,
campeni look,
I'm going to go black for now.
Body type, Airport fashion.
It's really my actual clothes.
Then, after bringing all these things, I'm
going to take them home.
Check
[Music]
Monday to the World The
Company
Neat
Black
Light Black Jean Black Black
Convert
Have a good day
Have a good day at
work
forry
You can do it
morning
way
here
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
Yes I have Tuesday  I'm in charge, but I'll stop by to
see what kind of clothes you have. I
don't know, this skirt is pretty too. What's pretty?  So I don't know. I
just want the color of the mirror to be taken from Monday to Sunday.
First of all, I'd like to point out the
small earrings that form a ring here,
and I'd like to
wear shoes at the end of the year there.  I
want my makeup to be as natural as I usually do, and I want my
lips to
have a moist and pretty look.
When I think
of LA, I think of the sea, so I went to the sea.
[Music]
I'm short, but since you're so tall, I
want to wear
something I can't wear.  I think
something like this is pretty. It's
really long. I'm a bit nervous. If I only
wear this, it'll be too cold. I
can do it. Only for taking pictures. But
the earrings are
so cute.  The end I am going to the sea.
This is a dress.
Actually, I don't wear long dresses because I am short.
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [
Music] While
filming, I
lost my earrings or bracelet during a dance break.  Inside, I've
broken a really expensive ring. It
was a dress with beads all over it, but while
dancing, this is all over the place, so
I'm like the dance lesson we often do,
Frozen,
our choreography, our choreography.
First of all,
[Music]
The shoes are fixed, the shoes.  The
three of us, who wash a lot, usually
don't practice on Thursdays. This is
really cute. It's so
cute. You wear a
lot of pants. You have to
wear a hat to look good
at dancing.
[Laughter]
I don't know anymore
[Music]
[Music] The
most important thing is to wear comfortable clothes that will be okay for a long flight.  I
secretly bring it, but
on the days I want to decorate the bathroom on the plane, it's
me with
training pants and
[Music] Yes, something with my
clothes today
doesn't look designer,
how
much is that?
This accessory
is the point. Bag like this
and now I'm only going to drink coffee, so
anyway, I've
never
done makeup or hair, so
please come with a full charge of caffeine.  I think you
really have to try and try on a lot to find something you do.
Everyone
can't always wear pretty, so I'd like you to correct it.
Hello, I'm Nayeon.
What was I?
I've seen it, it's so pretty. I'm obsessed with
long skirts
like this these days. I'm going to try styling something like this.
It's the concept of buying an oat milk latte and taking four shots of your life. This
long skirt.
Wearing a slightly vintage box steel, actually, I
wanted to wear a pendant-like necklace that came down a bit
this long.  Please wash the colored socks
as well.
Let the hair be natural.
[Applause] I
want you to give a point with a slightly glossy lip with a very natural make-up.
Make a case and
roll the yogurt next to the phone like shading with a cell phone line.
Then it's
over. Grab a latte and take a
good picture of your life.
Since you said it, I
decided on the concept of taking a walk with the dog.
Dogs
[Music] I
heard that their eyes look good in that blue color, so
I want to skip blue and clothes.
How about blue, buzz, blue
?  So
[Music]
Uh this I
[Music] It's
okay Wow Wow I
think we can take a pictorial I think I can
take a pictorial I'm a puppy
Where are the shoes?  I
wish I could wear that hairless cool ponytail so I can put the toilet pump in
when I go for a walk, and since I'm taking a walk with my dog ​​comfortably, I can
become a singer without makeup and make sure to put on sunscreen.
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
At that time, I wore a mask
Like a basketball player, I used to sing.
Yes, on my day off, I took the concept of doing the thesis forest
at home.
First of all,
I didn’t drink my own pants.  Does
n't everyone in America
wear shoes at home?  I
chose something flashy like this, my
hair is a bit ponytail,
no makeup, just lip
tears. Have fun
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
[Laughs]
I think it would be nice to wear a belt.  I
tried the look once, I
tried this leather vest, and I
thought it would look pretty if I did it on my waist like this with this shiny leather vest and cowboy boots like this,
and the
color of the hair was slightly
blue, so I thought it would go well with this guy with a little bit of blue, so
the dress and
hair are ah  A little bit of that, I
want my makeup to be cat-like, and the lip to be nude. I'm
going to a rock festival. How about me?
[Music]
[Music] I
hope you love this merit a lot.
I hope you will support me a lot.
Thank you
[Music]